Megan McCain pays tribute to her father
John McCain when you hear cancer a
nuclear explosion goes off in your life
yeah no matter who you are the view
co-host took to Twitter to honor the
late Senator who died at his home in
Arizona on Saturday after a longtime
battle with brain cancer he was 81 I
want when I leave that the ceremony is
at the Naval Academy and we just have a
couple of people that stand up and say
this guy he served his country in her
statement
Megan wrote quote in this loss and in
this sorrow I take comfort in this John
McCain hero of the Republic and to his
little girl wakes today to something
more glorious than anything on this
earth I'm still in disbelief if this
actually has happened and then I think
you know cancer chose the wrong guy
because they're gonna happen here
Megan's mom Cindy McCain also remembered
her husband on Twitter writing my heart
is broken I am so lucky to have lived
the adventure of loving this incredible
man for 38 years he passed the way he
lived on his own terms
surrounded by the people he loved in the
place he loved best the family announced
on Friday that John had decided to
discontinue medical treatment he was
diagnosed with a malignant brain tumor
called glioblastoma in 2017 other famous
memes have been taking to social media
to honor the late politician known as
the Maverick I am more energetic and
more engaged as a result of this because
I know that I've got to do everything I
can to serve this country while I can
President Trump tweeted my deepest
sympathies and respect go out to the
family of Senator John McCain meanwhile
former President Barack Obama released a
statement writing in part quote few of
us have been tested the way John once
was or required to show the kind of
courage that he did but all of us can
aspire to the courage to put the greater
good above our own at John's best he
showed us what
men and Hillary Clinton tweeted he was a
tough politician a trusted colleague and
there will simply never be another like
him celebrities like Mandy Moore took to
Instagram writing 60 years of service to
our great country a hero through and
through and Chaz Bono tweeted at a time
in our country when we desperately need
those who use their voice to speak out
with honesty and integrity the loss of
his will leave a vacuum I have feelings
sometimes of fear of what happens but as
soon as I get that I say wait man wait a
minute you've been around a long time
old man you've had a great life you've
had a great experience